유튜브 학과에서 배운 거는 좀 요리에 도움이 되던가요?
이 유튜브라는 거 이 자체가
너무 웃기다 나는 제대로 아니 제대로 배웠는데 지금
누구 앞에서 지금 제가
아 아니요 아니요
그니까 보면은 보세요 요리 독하 요리 체계적으로 배우셨죠
유튜브 독하 유튜브 체계적으로 배우셨죠
그니까 사실은 제일 가망끈이 길으세요
오늘 중식마녀님과 윤주모님 오셨습니다
네 반갑습니다
안녕하세요
자기소개 한 번 부탁드리겠습니다
안녕하세요 워그로 마술을 부리는 아줌마
중식마녀 이문정 셰프 인사 올립니다
안녕하세요 술빛낸 윤주모 윤나라입니다
조금 안쪽으로 들어오세요 여기 앞으로 해서
워그로 마술을 빚는 그 멘트가 유튜브에 고정으로 있더라고요
언제부터 이제 쓰시던 멘트인가요?
원래는 제가 6년 전에 유튜브 채널을 시작할 때
마녀 셰프였어요
마녀라는 캐릭터는 계속 이제 가져갔고
마녀라는 그 마 자에 마라는 글자에 의미를 많이 보였습니다
그래서 이제 마 자는 마라의 마 자
아 마라의 마에요?
강렬하고 그 다음에 중독성 있고
그래서 한 번 저 아줌마 마술의 마 아줌마의 마
여러 가지 뜻이 있어요 여러 가지
그래서 저 아줌마를 알면 강렬함에 빠져들어 헤어날 수 없다 중독된다
마력에
아줌마님 오셨는데 요즘에 그 업장 재오픈
네 4월에 재오픈해서 마감되었습니다
그러면은 쉬시는 동안 또 준비
쉬시는 게 아니고 재정비죠 재정비 하시는 동안 또 이거 바뀌어요 메뉴가?
메뉴는 이제 흑밀에서 나왔던 요리들이 많이 등장할 예정이고
테이블이 네 테이블이 있잖아요
그러면 이게 다 예약제로 되고요
다른 일하고 같이 하기가 힘들겠는데
약간 그런데 4월은 주말만 오픈을 했고 네 또 다른 일도 하고 애기도 봐야 되고 막 이래서
4월은 주말만 오픈을 했고 네 또 다른 일도 하고 애기도 봐야 되고 막 이래서
애기는 몇?
17개월 17개월
다 적고 계시네요
원래 안 적으시는 거예요?
아니 아니 계속 적어요
오늘따라 지척이 보이신다고 하네요
오늘 따라 지척이 보이신다고 하네요
17개월
프로파일로 갔다고 죄송합니다
멋있으시네요
이게 다 가능한 게 아줌마의 파워 입니다
아줌마의 파워때문에 이게 가능한 거라고요?
아니 아니 그냥 누나라고 해 주세요 뭐 아줌마예요
저는 그냥 아줌마
누나 누나 해 주세요
아줌마에 되게 이렇게 약간 자부심 이 있으신 것 같아요
그럼요
아 나는 이게 아줌마로서 헤쳐나갔다
네 인간이 이제 세 분위로 나뉜다고 합니다
누나 누나 너무 좋아요
남자 여자 아줌마
아 그래 맞아 이게 약간 옛날에 그런 말이 있었잖아요
처녀 때는 아줌마라는 말이 썩 기분 좋은 말은 아니에요
맞아요
약간 무시하는 그런 비하적인 발음 그런 느낌이 있었는데
왜냐하면 아줌마일 때 아줌마 이렇게 안 하고
그렇죠 왜 아줌마야 왜 내가 아줌마야
아줌마 이렇게 하잖아요 그러니까 그러니까 이제 보통 듣기
안 좋죠
네 그렇죠 그런데 이제 제가 아줌마가 돼보고 나니까 그리고 아이를
낳고 키우고 보니까 이래서 아줌마 가 강할 수밖에 없구나 그리고 여성
들이 이래서 오래 살 수밖에 없구나 남성들에 비해서
수명 얘기하시는 거예요
그걸 느꼈어요
네
남성 때문에 자부심을 느끼시는 거에요
모든 게 다
남자보다 오래 살아서
어차피 내가 오래 살 거다
나 오래 사는 사람이니까
내 남자보다 나는 오래 산다
나는 아줌마다 나는 아줌마니까 아저씨보다 오래 산다 그 자부심
이 있는 거거든요
그럼요 자부심이 있어요 있는 건 없지만 자부심만 있습니다
사실 유튜브가 독특하다고 유명한데 마인드가 굉장히 독특하세요 요즘
에는 어떻게 활동을 하세요 셰프 활동을
한 달 전쯤에 이제 퇴사를 25년 다녔던 호텔에 이제 퇴사를 했거든요.
그래서 지금은 제가 하고 싶었던 책도 좀 쓰고 있고
그리고 이제 유튜브도 열심히 하려고 하고 있고
그리고 이제 또 방송 같은 거 들어와서 이제 하고
결국은 저는 이제 요리를 하는 사람이라서
제 놀이터가 있어야 될 것 같아서
그것도 사업도 좀 구상을 하고 있습니다
그럼 동시에 여러 개 하시려면 좀 머리가 아프시겠는데요
그래도 해야죠
마녀니까
아줌마니까 난 마녀니까
아 다른
호텔 셰프들은 또 일반적인 셰프들하고 또 다른 게 있어요
뭐 예를 들면 윤주모님하고 이제 비교를 해보면
윤주모님은 가게 오픈부터 식재료가 뭐 어떻게 얼마고 뭐 이런 거 이제
경제적인 것까지 다 생각을 또 직접적으로 많이 하잖아요
그 호텔에 있는 셰프님들은 아무래도 뭐 계산은 해야 되겠지만
혼자 다 하시는 셰프님들보다는 요리에만 집중할 수 있을 거 아니에요
저희 같은 경우는 일단 인력이 많기 때문에
신입사원들 같은 경우는 열심히 일을 해야 되기 때문에
일을 많이 주고 이제 올라갈수록 수치적인 걸 계산하고 코스트를 계산하고
그런 업무적인 구분이 좀 더 있는 것 같습니다
아 그래요 저는 이제 요리사 하면은 다 요리만 신경 쓰시고
그 외부적인 뭐 운영이나 이런 거는 다른 팀이 해주는 줄 알았는데
그게 아니고 요리사에서 어느 정도 좀 관리하는 사람이 되면은 요리보다는 좀 그걸 더 신경 쓰는 거죠
셰프님들도 서류 작업 되게 많이 하신다고 들었어요
아 컴퓨터를 켜가지고요
제가 옛날에 그 편의점 알바했을 때 점장님이 맨날 그렇게 하셨어요
그 창고에 들어가서 막 이렇게 쓰시더라고요
뭐 발주하고 막 그거 하시는 거죠
관리 가장 중요한
근데 그걸 이제 어느 부서로 넘기면 그 부서에서 이제 식자재 발주를 해주고
또 큰 호텔에 뭐 그런 거 있다면서요 재료 손질해서 올려주는
그런 시스템도 있죠
그런 게 있다고 그러더라고요
셰프님들은 진짜 요리를 할 수 있게 어떤 부서에서 재료를 막 해서 올려준대요
그러면 이문정 셰프님은 완전 짱이었어요?
아니요 저는 짱이
완전 짱은 아니에요 그냥 마녀
오랜 세월을 했지만
제가 능력이 많이 부족해서
완전 짱을 못했습니다
마녀는 어느 정도
3짱?
어떻게 보면 제가 25년 경력이었는데 네 분이 제일 유력했었어요
다 저보다
경력이 25년이신데 어떻게 보면 운이 좋은 거라고 할 수 있겠네요 요리를 할 수 있으니까
저는 뭐 이왕이면 좀 짱이 되고 싶기도 했지만
마녀 말고 짱이 되고 싶은 사실은
짱이 되지 못하고
역으로 마술을 부리는 짱이 되고 싶었는데
아쉽지만 다른 무대에서 짱이 되면 된다고 생각을 합니다
말투가 좀 약간 독특하시잖아요
이게 호텔 용어예요?
저는 모르겠어요
호텔 사투리라는 말도 있어요 지금
호텔 사투리
제가 이제 학생들 가르치는 강의 활동을 많이 했어요
한 7, 8년 했는데 거기에서 좀 강의를 하니까 이런 말투가 좀 그렇지 않나요?
교수님이라고 다 이런 말투 쓰시진 않잖아요
그죠
교수님들은 반말 많이 해요
약간 군인 하셔도 진짜 잘 어울렸어요
지금 신랑을 안 만났으면 진짜 승진 많이 하셨을 것 같아요
군인이 돼서 생활하고 있었을지도 몰라요
군인이야말로 그거잖아요
승진 계속 할 수 있잖아요
군인이 맞았을 수도 있어요
저는 그런 것 같아요
신랑을 안 만났어야 되네요
신랑을? 신랑은 어떻게 하다가
저희 신랑은 이제 남자친구 고등학교 때부터
아이고 이 얘기를 안 하려고 했는데 큰일 났네
고등학교 때부터?
네네네 고등학교 때부터 만났습니다
지금 어디 보고 계시는 거 아니에요?
그래서 고등학교 때부터 이제 사겨서
입시 때 남편이 이쪽 가면은 좀 성공할 것 같다라고
요리 쪽으로?
네네 원주를 했어요
그래서 제가 또 고민을 하다가 재밌고 좋아하기도 했고
그래서 이쪽을 가야겠다
사랑하면 그런 게 더 보이나 봐요
딱 맞는 게?
네
그럼 비슷한 경험이 있어요?
정말 저도 동생이 하고 있는 일이나
그리고 저도
저는 저한테 추천을 했죠
그때는 이제 술을 빼면 쉬울 수 있으니까
손님들도 오시면은 얘기를 좀 그래도 하실 거 아니에요?
네네네
왜냐면 테이블이 좀 적으니까
네 하게 돼요
많이 얘기하시게 되면은 그 손님들한테 뭐 이런 거 조언도 많이 해주실 것 같기도 하고
아무래도 술집이니까 이제 술 마시면서 막 이런저런 얘기 할 거 아니에요
맞아요
같이 마시면 더 많이 하고
언니도 약간 그런 가게를 하고 싶어 하시는
저도
언니의 꿈도 저랑 비슷해요
추천하세요?
언니 진짜 잘하실 것 같아요
아
네
그러니까 뭐냐면은 웍 돌려가면서 마셔 하면서
마술을
마술을 부리겠어요
가게 안에서 노래 나오고
맛있어 맛있어
맛있어 맛있어 하고
여기 하나 티비 달렸는데 언니 유튜브 계속
유튜브 계속 나오고
24시간 돌아가고
또 너무 신나면
죽마월드
춤도 추고 사이키도 붙이고
언니 가게 이름 죽마월드에요 우리
아 죽마월드
육아에 지친 이들이 어서 와라
언니 분명히 아실 거예요
은주모님은
네
어떻게 시작하셨어요
저는 그냥 주변 사람들이 좋아하고 맛있다 맛있다 해줬고
맛있어 맛있어
네 그리고 그때 이제 전통주가 수면위로 올라오기 전이고 관심 받기 전이니까
나 같은 사람이 이거 하나는 해야지 약간 일종의 책임감 뭐 이런 것처럼
근데 왜 전통술에 이렇게 책임감을 느끼셨어요
그거 약간 문화 공연 기획을 하던 사람이기도 하고 한국 문화 전통문화를 사랑하기도 하고 또 예술을 전공하기도 했고
약간 지금 K 한류가 막 나가고 있는데
그거를 이제 저는 술로 돌린 거죠
아 한국술이 이렇게 맛있어 한국 음식이 이렇게 맛있어 막 공부하면서
원래 하시던 일이 있는데 결국은 하나를 선택해서 이제 집중을 해야 되잖아요
네
그럼 어느 계기로 딱
그냥 너무 몰입이 되고 빠졌어요 저도 직장생활을 하고 극장에서도 일했는데 단체생활이 힘들더라고요 저는
그래서 일단 그게 안 맞는다는 건 알았고 그리고 어디 갇혀서 사무실에 있으면 그것도 힘들더라고요
그래서 에 이거는 금방 그만둬도 된다고 생각을 했어요
이 전통은 다른 조직생활을 잘하는 사람이 지키고 이 술 전통은
난 이걸 지켜야지
혼자 해도 되니까 난 이걸 지키겠다
혼자 하는 게 되게 좋았던 것 같습니다
아
네 이거 작업하시는 시간을 즐기시는 편인가요
저 굉장히 안 즐기는 편이에요
그래서 이렇게 단체생활을 하시는군요
저는 좀 극단적으로 말하면은 감흥이 없는 사람이에요
감흥이요 그 감흥을 제가 끼워 읽게 만들어요
다 그냥 오케이예요
아 오케이
옛날에 그래서 말했던 게 예스맨
예스맨
그냥 이래도 좋고 저래도 좋고 그냥 뭐 이렇게 똑부러지게 뭐가 좋고 이게 잘 없어요
저는 그게 부러워요 이렇게 막 이거 하고 싶어 난 이게 좋아 뭐 이런 전통술 나 아줌마 뭐 이렇게
아 제가 좋다는 게 아니고 제가 아줌마가 좋다는 얘기야
이미 저의 매력에 빠지셨습니다
아니야 아니야 아니야 아니야 아줌마가 좋다는 게 아니고 아줌마가 아줌마를 좋아해
댓글 막 막 올라가면서
댓글 중독됐어 이제
댓글 중독됐어
큰일 났어요 이제
오해하지 마세요
밝히셨습니다
그래서 아 나도 이렇게 딱 눈에 띄게 좋아하는 게 있었으면 좋겠다
네
아 그래서 부럽습니다
술을 좋아해서 전통술을 좋아해서 하셨는데
네
요리는 또 어디서 배우신 거예요
그냥 요리는 독학이에요 진짜
그냥
네 책도 많이 읽고
그 흑인 요리사에 나온 것처럼 그냥
대단해 대단해
정말 만화 보고 요리를 배우셨다는 분들도 있잖아요
네
저도 방송 보고
최고의 요리 비결 한국인의 밥상 그때 뭐 올리브 티비 시작할 때였고
네
수민의 반찬 뭐 이런 거 보고 메모해 가면서 책 만들어 가면서 여러 개를 보고 만들었거든요
그거를 만들다 보면은 제 화가 되거든요 이론은 그래도 있어야 되지만
네
저의 맛을 구현하는 거는 이제 술도 마찬가지입니다 백날 배워도 제가
하지 않으면은 절대 제 게 되지 않습니다 맞죠 교수님
맞아요
네 그래서 제 걸 많이 하는 게
교수님
네 교수님
이렇게 안 배웠는데도 이렇게 하는 케이스가 있어요
그럼요
많아요
많지는 않죠 왜냐면은
근데 어떻게 이렇게까지 이렇게 계속 안 배우고 이렇게 잘했을지
하고 난 겁니다
천재예요 그러면
네 그렇죠 천재일 수 있어요
아인슈타인
아인슈타인 같은 거요 술 아인슈타인
네 앞으로 이제 그렇게 되실 뿐이고
수학을 수학 못 하기 때문에 네 맛슈타인
맛슈타인
빨리 지금 막 생각하고 있어
진짜로 그래서 내 입맛에 맞추다 보니까 사람들이 좋아하고 흑백 가서도 너무너무 많이 배웠고 뭐 이러면서 점점점점 저는 발전하고 있습니다
진화하고 있어요 진화
그러면은 일반적인 셰프의 그런 단계를 안 거쳤잖아요
네
그러면 뭔가 협업이나 이런 거
팀전이 제일 싫었어요 저는
그러니까 해본 적이 없죠
네
그러면은
그래서 우리 직원들이랑 일하는 거 밖에 없었는데 이게 저희 팀전이 파인다이닝처럼 굴러가는 거예요 약간 다이닝 셰프님들이 많아서 이렇게 규율 막 이렇게 해야 돼 움직이지 않아야 돼 막 이랬는데 저는 이제 혼자 하다 보니까 뭐 설거지도 했다가 이것도 썰었다가 모션이 약간 그렇거든요 팀전은 약간 힘들었고 혼자 할 때 너무 행복했고
근데 마피아 셰프님도 여기 나와서 그러시더라고요 혼자 할 때 너무 행복했어요
네
혼자 할 때 너무 좋았다고
팀전 힘드셨다고
근데 팀전은 힘들 수밖에 없어요 그날 딱 처음 같이 합을 맞추는데 잘 되기가 쉽지 않잖아요
근데 아마 이제 마피자 마피자
마피자님
마피자 셰프님도 이제 혼자 업장에서 자그마한 가게에서 하시다 보니까 저희는 그게 편해요
네 본인 스타일대로 하는 게
제 머릿속에 있는 거 이렇게 구현하고 막 보여드리고
대규모 미션이라 힘들었어요 10일
흑백 요리사에 막 안 나온 에피소드들도 많겠네요
너무 많죠 다 말할 순 없지만
막 살벌한 경우도 있었어요
아 살벌했죠
죽이네 살리네 너 해 나 안 해
오셨었어요?
아 그냥 나 그냥 말씀드리면 돼요 그냥 네가 이긴 걸로 쳐
아니 그냥 제 그냥 아무거나 던지는 거예요
우리 우리 우리
아 그래요? 그런 게 있었어요?
아무래도 연장이 있는 곳이기 때문에 언니 연장이 제일 무서웠지만 조심하려고 그랬죠
근데 혼자 하시는 경우도 있어요?
혼자 하시는 게 좋아서 하셨는데
네
지금도 혼자 하는 게 좋아요?
지금도 혼자
왜냐면 혼자 하면 힘들잖아
좀 키워봐야겠다라는 생각을 이제 해서 이따가 한 번 공개 구인하겠습니다 여러분
공개 프로포즈 하겠습니다
윤준왕 일하실 분 저한테 dm 보내주세요
한식을 사랑하시고 전통주의에 관심이 있으시고 한국 문화를 좋아하시는 분들이 계시면 dm 보내주십시오
요즘에 일손을 많이
네 이제 계속
필요성을 느끼시는구나
계속 혼자 했는데 이제 손님들
일환도 만나려고 하고 그리고 애기 손님들이 어린이 팬들이 많잖아요 언니도 연락 받으시고 그러죠
술 한 잔 거꾸로 와요?
그러니까요 이제 언제 만날 수 있어요 하면 우리 조카한테 20살에 친구들 손잡고 와
아직 14년이 남았거든요 너무 먼 얘기 같아서 한식이랑 이렇게 맛있게 즐길 수 있는 공간을 하나 만들고 싶다 이런 생각도 합니다
아니면 좀 크게 하면 어때요?
네 그런 공간을 좀 캐주얼하게 요구르트 말고
아기도 마실 수 있는 술이 있을 거 아니에요
네 무알콜로 맛있는 음료수를 주모가 갈아줄 수 있어요
그러면 이제 본격적으로 4월에 다시 시작을 하면은 또 다시 바빠지시겠네요
네 오늘도 이제 유튜브 촬영을 하고 왔고 제 걸 준비하고 있어서
유튜브도 뭐 또 따로
네 4월 초에 오픈할 예정입니다
그거는 이제 프로덕션이 같이
네네 그래서
저를 바로 따라오겠는데요
긴장이 아니라
혼자 하시잖아요
언니랑 같이 하시는데
중심 과장님은 혼자 하시잖아요
네네
제안 왔을 것 같은데
어 네 제안도 왔습니다
같이 하자고 프로덕션에서 같이 안 하신 이유가 있어요?
제가 생각하기엔 저의 이런 C급 감성은 누가 이걸 해 주실까
아 이 나의 그
결을 지켜야 되고
나의 결을
네
근데 그 막 되게 독특한 유튜브 있잖아요 막 유튜브 한번 볼까요?
음악을 만들어 했습니다
걔를 왜 때리셨어요 언니? 응?
애들 때린 거예요 신나서 아들 그래서 왜 걔
이게 언니가 가사를 쓰시고 에이아이는 작곡만 한 거죠?
네 음악은 아직 제가 배우지 못해서 가사는 근데
아 가사 직접 하신 거예요?
그래서 언니가 외우고 계신 것 같아요
재료 다 들어가고
에이아이가 그 가사까지 해 주시는 경우도 있는데 가사는
아니 근데 가사는 쓸 수 있으니까 가사는 써야죠 저에 맞게끔 영상에 맞게끔
불꽃도 잔인하네요
이걸 누가 이렇게 해 주시겠습니까?
이거 카피 가능할까요 편집자님들이?
똑같이 구현할 수 있을까요?
재능 있으신 분들 또 언니한테 이메일 좀 주시면 언니가
연락 드릴 거예요
효과만 좀 알려주시면
이거 똑같이 할 수 있다 그러면 언니한테 이메일 dm 주세요
가능은 해요
어느 정도 걸려요 이 작업 시간은?
저런 거 하면 뭐 기본이 그냥 한 달
영상 하나 만드는데 한 달 나와요
근데 꽃게 한 달 걸렸어요
왜냐면 제가 그것만 하는 게 아니라 저건 이제 저 회사 다녔을 때
출근 시간에 지하철에서 틈틈이 버스에서 틈틈이 그렇게 하고 하고 하니까 시간이 오래 걸렸죠
제가 봤을 때 그 중간에 박수 막 이렇게 이렇게
있잖아요 끝날 때 그거 안 되면 하루 줄 것 같은데
2분 안으로 줄이면
제가 무슨 말을 죄송해요 그러면 지금도 라이브도 하시잖아요
네 라이브도 이제 하는데 라이브로 컵방을 할까 하고 많은 기획과 함께 진행을 했습니다
또 파격적이어야 하기 때문에 구독자들 투표를 통해서 흑백요리사에서 선보였던 음식 은밀한 금난집
근데 그냥 은밀한 금난집이 아니라 금밀한 금난집이 아니라
은밀한 금난집이 아니라 금밀한 금난집이 아니라
그렇게 했는데 크게 시간대가 좀 일렀었던 것 같아요 6시 반부터 했는데
아 저도 맞아요 일으셨던 것 같아요
근데 이제 제 기대에 못 미치게 많은 분들이 안 들어오시더라고요
아 나 마녀인데
투표를 하는 오천 분 했는데
진짜 많이 해주신 건데
많이 안 들어오더라고요
이게 아닌가?
그러면 시간대를 약간 나중에 늦춰볼까요?
그래서 일요일날 한번 재도전을 해보려고 합니다
아 이번 주 일요일날 몇 신지
이번 주는 좀 늦은 밤 외계인들을 다 자기네 나라로 보내놓고
언니 언제 하신다고요 시간이
일요일 한 9시 정도
언니 냉부 시간이라고 안 될 것 같다고 그러시는데
그래서 안 본 거 아니에요 그때도 뭐랑 겹친 거 아니에요
냉부 대결
지금 냉부한테 대결 요청하시는 거예요
냉부 대결?
안 돼
우리 시간을 좀 다르게
그럼 다시 한번 고민해 보겠습니다
저희가 냉부 시간을 일부러 놓쳤습니다
비행기역이 짧았네요
큰일 날 뻔했네
감사합니다
아니 냉부를 안 보시네 보니까
그냥 언니는 한 명이랑 붙겠다가 아니라 그냥 전체를 다 내가 이겨버리겠다
저는 리모컨을 켜주고 있어요
그럼 집에 티비가 없어요?
있는데 티비를 볼 시간이 없었어요
남편분만 보세요?
남편분도 제가 남편분을 거의 못 봤기 때문에
왜냐하면 마녀니까
라이브는 대충 내용이 뭐예요?
제가 이제 작년에는 출근하면서 자전거 타면서 중국 음식 요리 명칭에 대한 거를 짧은 지식을 그냥 같이 전했어요
탕수육이 왜 탕수육인지 아냐 알고 먹자 이런 식으로 왜 라족인지 알고 먹자
강의네요
그렇죠
저도 재미있게 봤어요
출산 전에는 강의를 한 7 8년 정도 했었는데 출산을 하고 나서부터는 외부 활동을 일치할 수가 없던 환경이었어요
애만 보기에도 바빴으니까
그래서 그러면 내 채널에서
내가 하고 싶은 걸 다 하자
그래서 이제 그렇게 강의도 짧게 표현을 한 거고
그다음에 이제 오늘의 명언
오늘의 명언이세요?
명언 일기 필사해서
웍으로 마술을 부리는 중식 마녀의 채널인데 웍도 안 나오고
마술도 안 나오고 중식도 안 나오고 아무것도 안 나오는데 갑자기 명언이에요?
네
왜 명언이 또
그 명언은 어떻게 보면은 제가 이제 흑백 요리사를 촬영을 끝마치고
네
그런 고민과 불안함을 좀 느꼈던 것 같아요
아
그리고 어떻게 보면 이제 저희 같은 출연진들을 보면 거의 이제 자영업자 우리 사장님들 셰프님들 많죠
네
근데 이제 저는 직장을 다녔었고 주위에서는 그런 말들을 많이 했어
아이 누나 뭐해 빨리 노조해야지 빨리 나와서 장사해 지금 이런 건 뭐 기회야 막 이런 것 때문에 이제 만나고 나면 조발심이 느껴지는 거예요
만나고 나면 다 저들은 뭔가를 하고 것 같은데
시간 막 흘러가니까 조발심이 날 것 같은데
진짜 이게 기회인데 내가 못 잡는 거야
맞아 맞아
막 이런 그래서 심리적인
나 마녀인데
어
내가 마녀가 이걸 기회를 못 잡을 리가 없잖아
마녀라고 하지 말든가 엄청 센 척은 했는데 있는 건 없어 빚 좋은 개 살고
맞아
그런 심리상태를 겪다가 안 되겠다 내가 내 심리상태를 스스로 나 자신을 컨트롤해야겠다 그 좋은 글을 하루에 하나씩이라도 내 마음속에 좀 새겨서 마음의 노를 저어보자 라고 해서 오늘의 명언을 함께 같이 하자
좋은 거를 이제 좀 공유한다는 의미에서
네
나한테도 하는 얘기지만
그렇죠
그럼 좀 추천해 주실 만한 명언이 있을까요
추천해 줄 명언은 가장 이제 첫 번째 명언이 잊혀지지 않습니다.
내가 아침에 눈을 떴을 때 할 수 있는 일이 있다는 것에 대해 감사하라.
일반적으로 이제 회사원 생활을 하고 또 자영업자분들 똑같은 업무를 하지 않습니까
네
이제 많은 사람들이 힘들어 그냥 하루하루가 쫓기듯이 출근하고 퇴근하고 또 육아하고
네.
그런 생활을 하면서 내가 행복하다는 생각보단 힘이 들고 지치다는 생각을 많이 하는 것 같아요.
저도 그랬었고 근데 이제 그 명언을 읽고 내가 하루아침에 일이 없고 갈 곳이 없다 그건 너무나도 비극적인 것 같더라고요.
힘들지만 비록 출근할 곳이 있고 네가 해야 할 일이 있다는 것에 감사해라 마음가짐
그러면 일이 없으면요
일이 없으면 일을 만들어야죠
그럼 감사하게 안 해요
아니 일을 만들어야죠
나가서 일을 만들어라
그렇죠
어떤 일을
무슨 일이라도 해야죠.
무슨 일이라도 일이 없는 건 아닌 것 같습니다.
내가 좋아하는 일만 찾기 때문에
그게 꼭 직업이 아니고 내가 오늘 해야 되는 일 그걸 만들어라.
아니.
백수일 수 있어요.
여러분 잠깐 한시적으로 직업이 없을 수 있어요.
그렇죠.
문제없습니다.
그냥 좋아하는 거 하면서 책 읽고 영화 보고 만화책이라도 보면서 그 시간을 잘 버티면 언니가 아마
좋아하는 게 컴퓨터 게임이면
언니가 아마 뭐 하면 되지 않을까요
그럼요.
겪어가는 그냥 과정일 뿐이고 누구나 다 보이지 않는 그런 업무를 하는 것 같아요.
누구나 다 보이지 않는 그런 어려움 과 고난과 역경이 있습니다.
그렇기 때문에 저희는 많은 사람들이 특히 sns를 보면 좋은 것만 보지 않습니까
네.
그런 것들을 많이 보는 사람들이 또 불행하더라고요.
진심으로 죄송합니다.
빙산의 일각만 보는 것 같아요.
흑백뇸시사도 화려한 모습 유명해진 모습만 보는 거예요.
그런데 그 밑에는 저희는 너무나도 뼈렁깎는 고통들 이런 고된 시간
이런 것들이 다 있는 거죠.
화려한 것만 보지 마라.
네.
명언이네요.
이거는 중식마녀의 명언이네요 .
그렇죠.
그럼 오늘 명언 두 개가 나왔네요 .
네.
명언은 얼마든지.
그러면 윤주모님은 요리 특강 그런 거 재미있게 보셨다고 했는데
네.
언니가 재미있게 봤어요.
탕수육 기억나시나요
아니요.
그런데 이거 다 한문이라 다 어려워요 .
제가 기억할 수 없어요.
물 숫자는 아니죠.
탕탕탕의 탕자 아니죠.
육 고기육자.
다 한문 강의거든요.
필기를.
탕수육은 우리
나조기도 들어왔고.
탕수육인데 우리나라 요리에요 아니면 중국 요리에요
그러니까 저희가 먹는 스타일의 음식은 거의 이제 제가 이제 케이중식
이라고 명하는데 한국식 중화요리 인 거죠.
중국에는 이런 스타일이 없어요
그렇죠.
짜장면도 저희 나라 음식입니다.
고기의 음식.
이제 작작면이라는
저희도 기억나요.
작작면.
물 없이 아닌데
작작면 뭐예요
물 없이 자작하게 볶는다.
아니에요.
그럼 자작면이겠지.
작작면이 아니고
언니한테 배웠는데
작작면이라는 건 튀길 작자.
작는 이제 밥을.
자작면이 아니고
네.
가루 잔짤.
그래서 춘장을 튀겨서 면과 함께 비벼 먹는 음식이 짜장면이죠.
그것은 이제 중국에 있는 음식입니다.
윤남로 셰프님 닮았다는 사람 좀 심하네요.
아 올라왔어요 올라왔어요
너무하시네요.
아 그거 딱 바뀌죠.
그런 채팅은 되게
네.
거기만 꽂혔어.
확실히 전통 아니면 좀 관심 없어요
.
아 중국 전통은 약간 관심 없는 거
원래는
전통에는 관심 있으신데
네.
전통에는 관심 있어요.
우리나라 마라 마라 또 잘 모르고 먹잖아요.
왜요 마라가 또 뭔데요 모르시죠 전통이 아니잖아요.
마녀의 마음.
흑백요리사 때 워낙 이제 또 주목 을 많이 받으셨는데 윤주모님은
그 손떠는 거 굉장히 그 사람들이 관심 있게 봤잖아요.
네.
캐릭터가 됐잖아요.
지금 보니까 손을 안 떠세요.
이렇게 확 붙잡고 있어서.
제가 있어서 좀 편안하게.
네.
저희 언니랑 같이 있어서.
마녀 때문에.
마녀가 있어서.
떨지 마.
네.
팀전 올라갈 때도 언니 손 꼭 붙잡고 갔거든요.
안 떠지니까.
제가 뒤에서 음 이러고 있으면 떨려 뭐가 떨려 따라와.
그런데 그게 오히려 캐릭터가 됐 었어요.
왜냐하면 막 떨면 당연히 막 뭐가 제대로 안 될 거 아니에요.
그래서 아 저분은 너무 불안하다 떨어질 것 같아 했는데 이 악물고
계속 올라가니까 그게 캐릭터가 된 거야.
이 악물고.
웹툰에서도 막 그런 거 있어요.
막 살인 정보 업체가 캐릭터가 있는데.
그 얘기 하시는 거 들었어요.
봤어요
네.
엄청 잘 싸우는.
잘 싸우는.
막 붙으면서 떴는데.
코벤이.
맞아요.
계속 잘 돼.
저도 얘기 들었었어요.
코벤이 같다고.
계속 통과하고.
그런 캐릭터가 몇 개 있더라고요.
체인소맨 코벤이.
맞아요.
얼굴은 아닌데 안 닮았는데 예쁘더 라고요.
캐릭터만 닮았다고.
미인.
체인소맨 안 봤어요.
미소녀 아니에요.
이게 떤 이유가 진짜 그냥 무대가 커 가지고.
약간 그렇기도 하고 제가 공복에 좀 많이 떨기도 하고 장기간 저희가
서 있었거든요.
그래서 체력이 급격하게 떨어지면 또 긴장이 엄청 되면.
혈당 문제인가.
긴장을 하면 손으로 오는 게 약간 아기 낳고 좀 많이 생긴 것 같아요.
건강 이슈겠죠.
후유증이에요.
네.
출산 후유증.
그래서 병원 가보라고 많이 dm 많이 받았거든요.
그래서 병원 갔다 왔어요.
갔다 오니까 뭐래요.
뭐 그냥 이렇게 약간 심장이 빨리 뛰어서 이제 이쪽으로 올 수 있다고
.
그러면 이제 긴장할 때 술을 먹으면 좀 진전되는 거 없어요.
약간 그냥 말이 더 잘 나온다든가 뭐 이런 거 있잖아요.
조금.
근데 두 분이 어떻게 해서 친해지시게 된 거예요.
저희는 흑백요리사에서 이제 만났죠.
대기실을 이제 따로따로 다 썼다가 인원수가 많을 때 이제 올라가면서
다들 이제 집에 가시면 대기실이 적어집니다.
제가 둘째 날 언니를 처음 만났는데 모자를 이만큼 높은 걸 쓰고 있었어요.
이걸 쓰면 어떻게 요리를 하실 수 있지.
그럼 위에 파이프에 걸리는 거 아니에요.
주방은.
그래서 컴퓨터 하시는구나.
아니 아니요.
주방은.
주방에 못 들어가.
걸리고.
아니요.
나는 컴퓨터도 쓰고 있으니까.
나는 컴퓨터하고 발주하고 이런 음식 메뉴 레시피 이렇게 하는 사람이야.
옛날에 그 황제들 있잖아요.
황후들 손길 이렇게 길러가지고 나 일 못해.
약간 이렇게 과시하는 것처럼.
그래서 둘째 날 이제 첫 전제 대기실은 달랐는데 둘째 날부터 같은 대기실을 쓰면서 너무 친해졌고요.
그리고 이제 흑백 다 끝나고 기다리면서 또 자주 만나서 네 친해졌습니다.
언니 찬스로 워커힐 또 가보기도 하고 좋더라고요.
그래서 언니가 안 그만뒀으면 하고.
언니 좀 퇴사를 좀 미루시던가 아니면.
조금만 조금만.
아차산 아차산 있는데.
아차산 너무 좋다.
거기 좋아.
피자일 가봤거든요.
근데 언니가 그때 할인도 해 주셔서 가봤어요.
최초의 피자집.
네.
그거 먹으면서 언니 감사합니다.
거기 근데 진짜 위치가 너무 좋아요.
20대 때부터 일하셨구나.
거기 그렇게 사내다 이렇게 허가를 안 해 주잖아요.
그러니까 옛날에 해 준 게 그게 된 거잖아요.
그게 그 설이 있습니다.
네.
헤어졌던 연인들이 피자일에 와서 피자를 먹으면 다시 사랑을 나눌 수 있다라는.
그 피자일이 비싸서 그래요 언니.
비싸더라.
이 정도 사질 정도면 서로 사귀어도 다시 사귀어도 된다 그러네.
맛있긴 맛있는데.
너무 맛있죠.
멀리서 이렇게 가기에는 접근성이 좀 떨어져요.
그렇죠.
저희 호텔 자체가 그래요.
그 남도영 셰프님하고 또 친해지셨.
남도영 상우님.
네.
남도영 셰프래.
남도영 상우하고.
남도영 상우를 보고 셰프님이라고 그랬고.
입에 베서.
남도영 상우님도 자꾸 제가 몇 번을 셰프님이라고 그랬어요.
제가 남도영 씨랑 몇 번 봤는데 이야기를 진짜 많이 했어요.
네.
맞아요.
윤주모님 식당.
자주 오셨어요.
많이 갔다고.
공개되기 전에 이제 미리 오신다고 많이 오셨고 촬영 끝나고 dm 보내주셔서 전화번호 주고받고 동갑이시죠.
83 83.
세 살.
세 살 오빠들이시구나.
통천하고 나이 같네요.
통천 누군지 모르시죠.
아니요.
봤어요.
친 동생이세요.
네.
너무 웃기시네.
진짜예요.
제가 죄송합니다.
엄청 친해지죠.
띄엄띄엄 봐서.
친하죠.
그래서 그렇게 해서 친해졌어요.
네.
걔가 막 연락을 자주 막.
엄청 인싸시던데.
아 그래요.
네.
그리고 데리고 오신다고 몇 번을 하셨었어요.
저요.
제 얘기 많이 했었어요.
근데 그때 오픈을 안 하고 재정비 하고 있다고 그래가지고.
너무 궁금했는데.
오세요.
이제.
너무 가고 싶은데.
저같이 술 잘 못 먹는 사람도 가도 돼요.
오세요.
네.
남도영 성우님도 술 많이 못 드세요.
안주만 먹어도 돼요.
네.
안주 드세요.
오셔서.
그런데 술이 많이 나가야 테이블이 매상이 좋잖아요.
그런데 이제.
저같은 건 블랙컨슈머 아니에요 블랙컨슈머.
아니.
술집 가서 술 안 먹으면 블랙컨슈머 아냐.
그렇죠.
이제 주모 입장에서는 술 많이 먹어요.
그럼 계속 숨겼어요.
술 주문 안 하면.
에휴.
저것 좀 바르고.
이 깍개풀고.
아니.
뭐 농담으로 농담으로 이제 드린 말씀이지만.
네.
농담입니다.
이제 시킨다고 해서 그렇게 싫어 하시지는 않을 것 같고.
주모가 뭘 제일 싫어하겠어요.
왜 요즘에 세상 사람들은 무알콜의 시대로 가고 있는가.
그런데 이제 술을.
왜 술을 안 먹지.
술이 안 들어오면 이제 궁금하긴 할 것 같다.
네.
한 병만 드시면 되니까.
이제 가져가셔서 선물하셔도 되고 그런 걸로 요번부터 이제 바뀌려고
하니까 부담 없이 오셔도 될 것 같습니다.
그럼 이제 좀 체감을 하세요.
그 딱 흑백주사 딱 나왔고 나서부터 좀 어떤 반응이라든지.
그냥 제가 그동안 했던 거를 좀 많이.
네.
그냥 막 좋아해 주시고.
혼자 뭔가 하고 있었는데 알아봐 주시고 그런 느낌이어서.
음악 재밌어해 주시고 뭘 하던 응원해 주시고.
그래서 나가길 너무 잘했다.
이렇게 생각하고 있습니다.
중심 파일님은 뭐 그 흑백주사 나오고 나서 변화된 게 좀 있어요
저는 뭐 우선 구독자들이 이제 갑자기 늘어났고.
길 가면서 이제 아시는 분들.
사인해 달라는.
아 그런 분들도 계시고.
그리고 일단 제 유튜브가 많은 이제 시급 감성이고 영상미가 없었으니까.
네.
집에서도 많은 무시와 핍박을 받았습니다.
아이들 외계인들에게까지도 저의 채널을 많이 무시하고 했었는데.
이제는 네가 정답이다.
하고 싶은 대로 해라.
라고 이제 집사님께서.
엄마 이렇게 막 물어봤어 옛날에는.
아니 엄마 이게 뭐 이러니까 안 보지.
아 그럼 막 컨설팅을 해줘요 아이들이.
진짜 솔직하게 말하면 언니가 저희 대기실에서 만났을 때 유튜브를 하고 계신다고 말했어요.
그래서 저는 이제 구독을 일찍부터 했죠.
아들이 편집해 주는 줄 알았어요.
언니 그 마녀 이렇게 분장하시고 이런 거 있잖아요.
언니는 이거 안 하실 거다.
언니가 편집하는 게 아니다.
편집자가 언니 아들이다.
흑백주사 개봉하기 전에 다 내렸어요.
그때 영상들은 많은 연기가 있는 영상입니다.
되게 너무 재미있었는데.
바가지 막 뿔 쓰고 안녕 나는 마녀 셰프야.
이런.
이런 영상.
우리가 모르는 영상.
그러니까 저만 봐서 너무 답답한데 그거 보면서 이제 언니가 했을 리가 없다.
아들이다.
연기자로서.
지금 남아있는 게 수만맛이에요?
맞아요 맞아요.
매운 게 다 숨겨져 있어요?
지금 비곡이 언니 이제 기분 좋으시면 하나씩 풀 거거든요.
아니 10만 되면 나는 안 풀어.
10만 되면 지금 5만.
5만 5만.
그럼 5만 더 하면 하나 풀 수 있다.
노다지요 노다지.
설명만이라도 좀 해 주실 수 있어요?
어떤 식으로 안녕 나는 마녀 셰프.
연기가.
우선 복장이 틀려요.
제가 그냥 마녀로 등장을 해서 그 마녀가 이제 설명을 해 주는 듯이
난 이제 마녀니까.
진짜 많이들요.
나를 따라와.
그러면 너네도 요리를 나처럼 잘할 수 있다.
그런 멘트.
그런데 그럴 수 있는 게.
고수배 마녀 고수배.
어렸을 때 우레메 우레메를 보던 세대라 저는 충분히 이해가 됩니다.
여러분도 보시면 제 심정이 이해가 가실 겁니다.
언니가 했을 리 없다.
그래서 술자리에서.
술자리에서 그걸 하나 보여줬어요.
삐딱한 천재가 이거 무조건 무조건 이거 100만 간다 이거는.
그래도 아껴놓고 계시니까 언젠가는.
이거는 위험해 이거는.
집사님이 일단 싫어하십니다.
왜요 그걸 왜 싫어하세요.
그러니까 그분은 이제 성향이 저랑 좀 반대예요.
소극적이고 이제 내향적이고.
저는 이제 반대인데 요리만 해라.
왜 뭘 안 해.
.
그거는 모든 본 사람들이 다 한 번은 했을 생각이에요.
아니 왜 요리만 안 하 돼요.
언니가 쿠팡 하는 건 약간 형부의 바램이고 언니의 본 모습은.
그렇죠.
과거의 방송에 있고.
라이브쿡빵은 집사님이 요청해서 한 거 같다.
약간 아니면 그 상황극에 이런 갈망 이.
아니 그리고 또 그때 당시에는 이제 제 채널 이름이 마녀 쉐프였어요
.
이름은 마녀 셰프인데 이 영상을 보면 마녀의 이런 느낌이 안 난다.
그래서 좀 그걸 좀 살려보면 어떻겠냐 라고 교수님께서 조언을 해 주셔서
그때는 이 열정이 진짜 하루하루 타올랐습니다.
캐종대학교 사이버대학교 유튜브학과는 엄청난 곳이에요.
그렇죠. 그래서 진짜 그런가? 탈바가지나 좀 써보고 마녀 나는 이제 마녀다 라고 이제
교수님이 추천해 주셨더니
교수님의 추천이었어요?
어. 최면수학과. 진짜 처음 들어요. 충격적이에요.
그러니까 그 학교가 세종사이버대학교 유튜버학과 정확하게 뭘 배우는 거예요? 유튜브 만드는 거?
네. 그래서 이제 기초부터 핸드폰으로 유튜브를 시작하는 방법 프리미어 프로 영상 편집하는 기술 인스타에 관련된 것도
이제 sns에 관련된 모든 것들을 이제 체계적으로 공부를 하죠.
보통 그 유튜브 학과는 한 몇 년 정도 배우나요?
4년 과정이에요.
아. 4년이에요?
네. 그런데 이제 저는 편입이 돼서
제 마음대로 2년일 거라고 생각했는데
편입이 돼서 학점 인정을 해줍니다. 그러면 편입이 되면 이제 5년 과정이에요.
그럼 덜 배워도 돼요? 학점 인정 받으면?
아니요. 그 4년보다는 덜 배우겠죠. 학점이.
보통 1학년 2학년 때는 교양을 많이 들으니까 그걸 이제 빼주고 전공만 들어라 이런 거.
그런데 저는 그 수업이 너무 좋아서 일부러 졸업을 늦게 했어요.
음...
그러니까 졸업 시점에
예를 들어서 인스타를 배울 수 있는 그런 과목이 생기는 거예요.
그러면은 너무 듣고 싶은 거예요.
그래서 그냥 졸업을 유예하고 또 그거 듣고 열심히 듣지는 못했지만.
저는 되게 가볍게 사이버대 유튜브 학과 이러니까 느낌이 좀 가볍잖아요.
막 뭐 정치 외교학 뭐 이런 게 아니니까.
그러니까 저는 한 2년 정도 배우고 딱 필요한 거 딱딱딱 배우는 건 줄 알았는데
4년 동안 되게 길게 배우는 거예요.
어. 그럼요.
윤주모님은 학과가 연극...
영화과.
연극 영화과?
그럼 거기서 뭘 하는 거였어요?
뭐 극본이에요? 뭐 연기예요?
저희 때는 연기 전공, 영화 연출 전공, 제작 전공, 또 뭐 카메라 전공 다 같이 뽑아놓고서는 수업을 같이 들어요.
그 대신 이제 파트별로 분배를 해서 요거는 이제 요만큼 뽑겠다.
그래서 경쟁률이 되게 셌어요.
지금도 많이 셀 텐데 저희 때도 세서 다른 과로 붙어놓고는 가야겠는 거예요.
예대는 거기 하나만 썼거든요.
네.
그래서 바로 갔습니다.
어. 근데 예대로 고른 이유는?
그냥 예대 가고 싶었어요.
예술이 하고 싶었어요?
예고부터 가고 싶었는데 예고는 못 갔고.
예술에 대한 갈망이 있었구나.
네. 갈망이 있었어요.
고등학교도 못 갔으니까.
네. 개원이나 뭐 안양이나 뭐 가고 싶었는데.
마녀도 아닌데.
네. 아닌데.
예술하고 싶어서.
내가 그 축가로 갔었어야 됐나 봐.
그러면 그 학교에서 배울 때 뭘 생각하고 하신 거예요?
저는 한국 영화에 황금기에 들어갔기 때문에
영화를 하려고.
네. 영화 제작이나 배그 뭐 홍보 아니면 기획을 하고 싶었어요.
그 뭐.
영화사에 들어가고 싶었죠. 한마디로.
아. 거기 들어가서 그 직접적인 제작을 하는 사람들도 있잖아요.
네. 맞아요. 스텝이 될 수도 있는데.
영화를 찍고 스텝이 되고.
저는 그때도 단체생활이 안 맞는다는 걸 금방 알았어요.
그래서 이제 스텝이 되는 거는 진작에 저거 했고.
그래서 하다가 보니까 극장생활도 하고 공연도 하고 그러다 보니까
뭔가 제가 하는 활동에도 맞더라고요. 한마디로.
뒤에서 멀리 보잖아요. 스텝들은 이렇게.
근데 이제 무대에 있는 사람이 멋있어 보이고.
근데 저는 이제 윤주당에서 할 때는 제가 하고 싶은 대로.
생각한 대로 펼칠 수 있는 공간이니까.
지금이 훨씬 더 맞는 것 같아요.
그래서 영화 제작 뭐 공연 기획 뭐 이런 것도 배웠고.
연출도 배우고 카메라 시나리오 작법 다 배우거든요.
그런 게 이제 모든 게 도움이 돼서 이렇게 가게를 운영하고 있는 것 같습니다.
아까 배웠던 게.
네. 그럼요.
유튜브 학과에서 배운 거는 좀 요리에 도움이 되던가요?
요리예요?
네.
그러니까 제 채널에서 제 요리를 정말 멋있게 못 다뤄서 그렇지
아주 훌륭한 자기만의.
자기만의 기록을 남길 수가 있죠.
그 기록들은 결국 역사가 될 것이고.
다시 오세요.
네네.
그래서 아주 아주 좋은 수업입니다.
그래서 제가 처음에 그 세종대 유튜브 학과 다닐 때 전도사였어요.
제가 중국어 학원을 다녔어요.
그래서 그 선생님을 이번에 제가 추천을 해서.
잠깐만요.
중식만 회원님 못 참고 웃으신 것 같은데.
지금까지 웃음 참으신 거 아니에요?
아니에요.
아니에요?
네. 그래서.
웃음이 났는데 지금까지 계속.
억지로 참으신 것 같아서요.
그 분이지?
아니에요.
드디어.
그래서 그 분 제가 이번에 추천을 해서.
네.
세종대 학교 지금 다녀왔어요.
웃긴 얘기가 아닌데 왜 웃으세요?
좋아서.
열심히 지금 라이브 하고 계십니다.
아 네.
곧 좋은 결과가 있을 거라고.
언니 저한테 추천을 줬다고.
그럼요.
이 유튜브라는 거 이 자체가.
너무 웃기다.
아 이거 해주세요.
제대로 아니 제대로 배웠는데 지금.
누구 앞에서 지금 제가.
아 아니요.
아 여기 진짜 유튜브 선물이다.
언니가.
아 그래요.
제대로 배우신 분입니다.
죄송합니다.
그러니까 저는 독학이고 사실은 그렇죠.
네.
그러니까 보면은.
그런 느낌.
보세요.
요리 독학.
요리 체계적으로 배우셨죠.
유튜브 독학.
유튜브 체계적으로 배우셨죠.
그러니까 사실은.
언니 모든 게.
제일 가망끈이 기르세요.
그래서 연기를 한 번 해보시는 것도 저는 좀 추천드립니다.
알겠습니다.
예.
아니 연기를 굉장히 잘하실 것 같아요.
이제 저희 집사님께서 또 이제 무슨 말을 하시는지 모르겠지만.
집사님한테 미움받는 거 아니에요.
괜찮습니다.
아 괜찮습니다.
연기를 한 번.
집사님이 그 봉인을 했는데 겨우 봉인했는데 제가 괜히 또.
이제 오디션 보고 다니시는 거예요 언니.
그러니까요.
이것도 새로운 걸 또 배워야 되니 또 열정을 또.
직업은 뭐 다양할수록.
그런데 또 이제 한식하고 중식을 또 따로 하시는데 차이가 있어요
.
뭐든지 그 구분 짓는 거에 가장 큰 거는 저는 식자재라고 생각을 해요
음.
다르는 게 달라요.
왜냐하면은.
네.
다르죠.
또 이 말이 말을 많이 할 것 같아요 .
늘 말이 많아서.
이 나라 각각의 그 자연 환경에 따라서 식재료가 틀리거든요.
그렇게 되면.
여기까지 하겠어요.
아니 뭐 얘기하신 게 없어요.
되게 많기 때문에.
아니 아니 너 너무.
네.
그만해라 하시는.
아니 아니.
아니 전혀 그렇지 않아요.
여기까지 하자.
아니 말씀이 너무 웃기셔가지고 .
식재료에 따라서.
음.
일단 음식이 많이 바뀌고.
왜.
아니 아니.
말씀이 너무 재미있어서.
왜.
그래서.
조리법이 이제 가장 큰 거죠.
조리법이 이제.
어.
중식이 이제 불을 활용해서 하는 그런 조리법이.
센 불로 해야 돼요.
중식은.
아무래도 센 불로 해서 이런 수분 을 날리는 볶음의 조리법 같은 것들이
한식과는 이제 많이 이제 차이가 있죠
그래서 중식이 되게 화려하고 멋있어요 .
한식은 좀 얌전하게 삶고.
깔끔하고.
그렇죠.
소스 같은 거 조미료 같은 것도 되게 디테일하게 놓고 써요.
간장 몇 종류 소금 몇 종류
중식이 특징이 또 양념이 많은 게 또 특징이에요.
같은 소금도 여러 개가 있어요?
소금 하나인데 구워서 쓰는 소금이 있고
그다음에 오양을 넣은 소금이 있고
바베큐에 쓰고 요리에 따라서 양념이 많이
그렇게 있고요.
그렇죠.
윤주문 님은 되게 디테일하게 쓴다는 얘기를 들었거든요.
네 저는 조금
간장 몇 종류
간장도 10년짜리 한 번 숙성한 거 흑백에 가져갔었거든요.
그럼 이제 수분은 날아가고 굉장히 응축된 그런 콩의 맛이 나요.
그걸 썼을 때가 있고
국간장 할 때는 청장이라고 그냥 얕은 간장
만든 지 한 1년 안 된 그런 매주 간장 쓰고
또 조금 진간장 그게 숙성이 되면 또 다른 맛이 나거든요.
그래서 원물에 따라 매주 콩 맛에 따라서도 많이 나지만
숙성 연도에 따라서도 맛이 달라서
제가 막 여기서
비싼 재료를
비싼 재료 싼 재료 해 가지고
체험해 보는 방송을 한 적이 있었어요.
비싼 재료 싼 재료
그래서 막 비싼 소금 싼 소금 해봤어요.
막 먹어보고
하셨어요?
아 진짜요?
그냥 막잎이라 그런가 저는
이제 그런 것들을 어떻게 풀어내느냐가 이제
셰프들의 기술이 아닌가 싶어요.
근데 소금 하나 쓰신다면서요.
소금 하나 쓰신다고 했는데
일반 사람들은 잘 모르니까 그냥 하나 쓰시는 거 아니에요?
응.
그냥 소금에서 필요한 게 염도.
염분이 염화나트륨이긴 한데
거기서 단맛도 있고 미네랄도 있고
오늘 그러면 좀 간장을 좀 여러 종류로 저희가 좀 갖고 오신 것도 있죠?
네. 갖고 왔어요.
이거를 먹어볼 수가 있을까요?
맛을 제가 느낄 수 있는 정도예요?
네. 아마도?
소금은 잘 모르겠다고요.
소금 하나 쓰시는 게 맞는 거 같아요.
소금이 조금씩
이게 이게 맨날 설탕 설탕이고
색깔 색깔부터 다르다. 색깔부터 다르다.
색깔부터 다르다. 색깔부터 다르다.
네. 색깔부터 다르다. 색깔부터 다르다.
그래서 손에다 올려놓고 먹는 거예요?
어. 셰프님들은 그렇게 하시더라면.
저 셰프님처럼요?
조금씩 조금씩 드세요.
손 안 씻으셔서 여기서 짠맛 올라온 거 아니냐고.
아 손 씻고 와야겠다.
아 맞네.
거의 뭐.
아 그런 거 같아. 내 짠맛 같아.
여기 M이야 짜다 나왔어. M이야 짜다.
그래도 짭니까?
네.
끝에는 좀 물 하나 드시고 물
아 단맛이 올라와요.
색깔이 이거는 이렇게
맑아요.
네. 맑고
이거는 조금 진하고
이거는 약간 더 진하죠.
근데 이 두 개를 구분을 못 하겠어요.
아 못 하시겠어요?
네. 그냥 간장.
지금 요즘에 어디 식당 가서 컨설팅 해주시는 거 하지 않나요?
아 그래서 음식 맛은 제가 다 맛있어서 컨설팅을 못 하고
근데 제목이 컨설팅이잖아요.
컨설팅 하려고 한 게 아닌데
잘못됐어요.
이런 거. 그러니까 명칭.
이거는 되게 달아요.
드셔보니까 이게 달죠.
이게 식판 간장이에요.
이게 식판 간장이고 드시던 거.
그럼 이게
이거 식판 쓰면 되는 거 아니야?
아닌가?
아 내가 무슨 말을
아니 내가
안 좋은 건가? 당도가 있으면?
뭐 이런 거 하실 땐 설탕을 좀 둘러시면 되죠.
그리고 이거는 이제
전통 방법으로 만든 메주로 발효시킨 간장입니다.
이거는 청장이라고 국간장.
미역국 하거나 그럴 때 쓰는 거고
이거는 뭐 다른 집에서 만들었지만
조금 더 오래 숙성하면 이렇게 색깔이 진해져요.
옛날에는 이런 뭐 샘표나 이런 데서 나온 간장이 없기 때문에
다 이런 걸 썼죠.
중식 마녀 셰프님은 이거 구별이 되세요?
그러니까 이거 같은 경우는 그냥 맛이 가벼운 느낌?
응. 그래서 복합적인 맛보다도 그냥 아짜.
아짜?
어. 아짜.
칸맞추기.
이런 느낌.
그래서 이거는 이제 짜면서도 복합적인 맛이 좀 들어있는.
아 짭짤한데.
아짜.
어. 아짜.
이거는 짜고 달고.
간장 향은 못 맡아보셨죠? 한번 맡아보세요.
되게 좋은 향이 나요. 좋은 간장은.
빨래냄새.
빨래냄새요?
일단 자꾸 이 간장 맡으면 빨래냄새가 나지.
빨래냄새.
빨아야 되는 거.
빨래를 해야겠어요.
그러면은 확실하게 차이가 난다고 하셨죠?
블라인드 테스트 해도 돼요?
어. 네.
맞출 수 있겠어요?
호영 언니는 너무 가능하실 것 같은데.
너무 쉬워요?
네.
경력 25년이니까.
큰일 났네.
좀 걸려 있잖아요. 명예가.
1번, 2번, 3번 이렇게 맞추면 돼요.
다시 한번 물어봐 주시겠어요?
네.
네?
뭐 어떤 걸요?
섞어?
섞지 마라.
마녀는 할 수 있다.
어. 섞지 마.
몇 번이에요? 1번인가?
1번이 2번인데요?
확실해요?
섞은 거 아니면 2번.
2번이 그거였잖아요. 아 복합적이다. 복합적인 맛이 나요?
난 단맛이 안 나요.
3번은 절대 아니고.
네.
섞지 않았으면 2번.
오케이.
이건 3번.
이거 3번이요?
아니 2번.
2번?
2번 아까.
1번 했는데 2번 2번이에요?
아 함정일 것이다. 그럼 아까 그거랑 똑같다.
첫 번째 한 것도 2번, 두 번째 한 것도 2번.
야 이거 함정까지 간파를 하셨는데?
자 그러면은 세 번째.
눈을 감아야 돼.
왜 눈을 감아?
보이니까. 보이니까.
색깔이 보이니까.
이거 1번이네.
오 이건 1번.
어우 짝.
오케이. 자 돌아보겠습니다.
근데 이 맛이라는 것이.
앞에 거랑 또 영향을 주잖아요.
그럼요. 그래서 이걸 맞춘다는 것은 정말 어려운 일이라고 생각을 해요.
너무 짭짭.
그 마녀 셰프님이 하나만 쓰시는 이유가 있어요.
언니 죄송해요.
아니.
왜 계속 2번이지?
하나만 쓰는 것도 좋아요. 사실.
2번, 3번, 1번이냐?
1번, 2번, 1번.
1번, 2번, 1번?
이거 본방송에 내지 말아주세요.
네?
응?
자를까요?
아 괜찮습니다.
아 괜찮아요?
괜찮으면 뭐 어때요?
헷갈릴 수도 있잖아요.
모를 수도 있지.
괜찮습니다.
감사합니다.
그렇죠. 집중하기 힘들고.
간장은 하나 쓰시죠?
간장?
네.
업장에서.
간장 하나죠.
하나 써요.
간장 하나, 두 반장 하나.
그러니까요. 간장을 여러 가지 쓰셔서.
그러니까요.
왜.
간장을 한 번만 쓰신 거 아니야.
여러분들한테 알려드리고 싶어서. 간장이 이렇게 많이 있습니다.
그런데 확실히 그런데 냄새를 이렇게 싹 맡으면서 들어가야 되는데.
맞아요.
그냥 바로 입에 들어갔잖아요.
아.
이것도 사실 음식을 즐길 때.
맞아요.
향이나 이런 게 들어가는 건데.
셰프님들은 이렇게 디시가 오면 무조건 코로 정보 확인부터 하시더라고요.
그럼 네 명이서 먹으면 어떡해요?
그러면 자 막내가 들어.
자 붙어.
이렇게 해요?
돌아가면서 이제 네 명이.
아 돌아가면서.
형부터?
어른부터.
그렇죠.
가는 거죠.
형이나 뭐 언니부터?
그렇죠.
저는 좀 냄새 날아갈 때쯤 이제 맡고.
그래서 항상 이제 습관적으로.
향부터?
네.
향부터 맡으시면 됩니다.
제가 음식점 가서 향을 안 맡았는데.
100% 즐기지 못한 거네요.
그렇죠.
그래서 그거 하시면 돼요.
앞으로 냄새를 꼭 맡아보는 걸로.
알겠습니다.
그래서.
본인은.
아니.
이거는 명예가 걸려.
싫어도.
내 네 명예는.
마녀잖아요.
마녀마녀니까.
마녀니까.
하지 말죠.
그렇죠.
명예가 걸려야 된다.
하나만.
저 혼자 죽겠습니다.
하나만요?
저 혼자 독감하겠습니다.
일단 단 하나만 해보세요.
하나만?
네.
오 그래요?
그러면.
코가 막혀요.
하세요.
그러면 오케이.
코가 막혀요.
코가 막혔어요?
어.
코가 막히면은 고르기 어렵습니다.
그래요?
그러면 한번.
그럼요.
감기 걸려서.
저도 사실 감기 걸려서.
아 그래요?
어 그러면.
아니 아까 괜찮.
아까는.
괜찮다고 해야죠.
그럼요.
목소리부터 틀리지 않습니까?
그런 것 같기도 하고.
네.
물 좀 많이 먹고.
물 좀 드시고.
지금 머릿속에서 이제 생각을 하실 거예요.
첫 번째로 과연 1번을 줄까 2번을 줄까.
그런데 3번을 줄 일은 없다.
왜냐하면.
그렇죠.
너무 티나니까요.
그러면 1번 2번에서 아마 좁히실 거예요.
그래서 이거.
그래서 요거가 지금 사실 찍기만 해도 50%예요.
설마 저는 알겠죠?
그렇지.
아 이게 알 수 있을까?
어?
지금 섞는 소리 아니죠?
아니 이거를.
이게 안 떠져서.
그거를 빙자한 거예요.
네.
짠.
이거 맞히기 어려울 것 같은데.
지금 바로 대답이 안 나오는 거 보니까.
머릿속에 지금 계산을 많이 하고 있어요.
어.
지금 섞었다는.
지금 이렇게 여러 번 부딪히니까.
지금 섞었다는 게 들어와서.
지금 50% 원래 찍은 거예요.
죄송합니다.
50%거든요.
50% 먹는 간장 맛인데.
나를 혼란스럽게 하는구나.
분명히 이거.
지금 선택지가 더 추가가 됐거든요.
이거 개미했다.
자 그러면 이렇게 할게요.
1번 1번 간장.
2번 2번 간장.
3번 3번 간장.
4번 1번 2번 섞은 간장.
5번 2번 3번 섞은 간장.
6번 1번 3번.
아니야.
3개 다 섞은 거.
1번 2번 3번.
1번.
1번?
네.
안 섞였다?
확실한 1번이다?
몰라.
이게.
사람이 심리 상태라.
그러면은.
알려드릴게요.
섞었어요.
뭘 섞었을까요?
1번 2번.
1번 2번 섞었다?
아니요.
오.
알겠습니다.
다시 들어보시고.
맞혔습니다.
와.
감사합니다.
약간 1번이 더 맛있어진 느낌이었어요.
네.
명일은 지켰어요.
감사합니다.
휴.
마녀님 어떻게 다시.
아니.
네.
지우겠습니다.
진짜 감기신고 같아요.
주말에 외계인들 데리고 서울랜드 갔다 왔습니다.
외계인은 지구의 놀이기구를 많이 좋아하던가요?
네.
가족 구성원이 집사 마녀 외계인 둘인가요?
맞습니다.
집사님까지 외계인이 셋이죠.
집사님도 외계인이에요?
그렇죠.
저와 다른 세계관을 가진 사람들이 다 외계인입니다.
그럼 지구는 한 명밖에 없을 텐데.
아니.
근데.
저요?
저 외계인이에요.
아니.
무조건.
굳이 부정하지 마세요.
아니.
대화를 해보니까 저는 완전 결이 다른 결이에요.
저는 완전 외계인이에요.
저는 왜 비슷하게.
다음이 지금 준비가 되어 있는데.
너무나 감사하게도 두 분이 요리를 해 주실 수 있다고 해가지고.
사실 제 스튜디오가 요리를 할 수 있는 환경은 아닌데.
브루스트 하나 있거든요.
화비가.
그래서 좀 힘들지만.
중식 하나.
한식 하나.
그렇게 한번 맛을 보려고 합니다.
좀 음식을 소개해 주실 수가 있을까요?
음.
윤주모님부터요.
아.
저는 이제 주제를 선정을 해 주셨죠.
네.
주제가 바로 닭입니다.
닭.
닭이라서 저는 닭볶음탕.
나중에 밥 볶아드리려고 밥도 가져왔어요.
윤주모님이 가져온 밥이니까 또 굉장히 디테일했겠네요.
디테일한 햇반입니다.
쌀도 여러 가지가.
쌀도 여러 가지 쓰시던데.
아니요.
그냥 또 그 뭐.
볶을 때는 햇반이 맛있어요.
그리고 중식 마녀님은.
저는 이제 중국에 보면 이제 북경 오리가 있는데.
예.
닭으로.
조이법을.
예.
북경 닭?
네.
단 주의해야 될 게 기름을 사용해서 이 닭을 기름으로 뿌려줘야 되기
때문에.
맞아요.
이렇게 기계하잖아요.
네.
잘못하면 터질 수도 있습니다.
그래서 그런 긴박한.
옆에 윤주모님은 의식하신 건 있어요?
좀.
제가?
네.
아니.
왜요?
이번에 이겨야겠다.
네.
음식의 대결은 중요하지 않습니다.
중요하지 않군요.
그럼요.
이 음식으로 어떻게 이제.
이건 정형화된 게 아니니까.
아.
그것이 가장 중요한.
저희는 하고 싶은 걸 할 뿐입니다.
그러나 이기면 좋죠.
여러분.
아니.
대결이 아닌데.
아니요.
일로 와봐요.
잠깐만.
아니.
본인이 말했잖아요.
본인이 말하는 거 아니야.
환기를 좀 해놓는 게 나을까?
안 터질려면.
아니.
그 정도는 아니고.
왜요?
지금 긴장하셨어요.
아니.
왜냐하면 집에 외계인이 있어요.
여기서 죽을 수가 없어요.
맞아요.
걱정 마시오.
저는 외계인이.
둘.
셋.
네.
알겠습니다.
그럼 바로.
네.
요리 한번 들어가 보도록 하겠습니다.